and we're always watching TV and she's  forever getting teared up and I am  laughing my ass off like she used to  watch The Biggest Loser and these these  fat people would be crying  about all the cookies and burgers they  were eating  and they were crying like they lost a  dog or something and she would be crying  that I would just be laughing my ass off  no most of the world is starving that's  why like I went to like India and I saw  this level of poverty that I just maybe  want to adopt every kid over here and  then you just come back to America and  this is slobbingly feel I just can't  stop me ignoring us it was just so  [ __ ] hilarious  my wife gets mad at me for laughing it  makes it like  oh dude I have worse ones than that